mich beschäftigt die Panikmache der
Politik die Zeitung Welt berichtete
heute Wappen sich Städte und Gemeinden
schon für den Ernstfall steinfurz
Landrat Martin Sommer waren eindringlich
vor Stromausfällen die länger als 72
Stunden gehen der Kreis Viersen geht
sogar noch weiter und dreht seinen
Bürgern wie übrigens auch viele andere
Kreise sich für eine mögliche
gasmangelage oder Stromausfälle
vorzubereiten die Rheinische Post
liefert direkt mal die Tipps mit man
sollte Bargeld im Haus haben Essen 14
Tage und zwei Liter Flüssigkeit pro
Person pro Tag den Bürger wird also auch
noch erklärt wie man eigentlich am
besten ein Vorrat aufbaut als könnte er
das nicht ich frage mich wie kommt man
auf solche infantinen Vorschläge und
warum verbreitet die Politik derartige
Blackout Panik fakt ist gemessen an den
Füllständen unserer Gasspeicher können
wir vorerst halbwegs entspannt in den
Winter gehen am Dienstag teilte die
Bundesnetzagentur erst mit dass die
aktuellen Füllstände bei 92% liegen
damit sind wir im soll die Gasversorgung
ist also in Deutschland aktuell stabil
mich befremdet dieses in der
Gesellschaft herrschen schaltet das
Licht aus bleibt zu Hause spart Gas legt
euch Vorräte an morgen geht die Welt
unter erst war Corona Schuld jetzt die
Energiekrise und ich möchte von Herr
Bruder wissen wann hört die Politik
endlich auf den Menschen solche Angst zu
machen Herr Bruder ich will gar nicht
ausschließen dass die Politik diesmal
richtig liegt das wird tatsächlich die
Katastrophe von der gewarnt wird
vielleicht bald erleben werden keine
Panikmache sondern das ist schon Panik
mache das tolle ist ja beides auf einmal
es ist einmal die Warnung von einem
Notstand der eintreten könnte wo ich
glaube auch eintreten wird und zum
anderen ist das natürlich Panikmache es
ist die Fortsetzung der corona-politik
möglichst viele Leute einen
Wohlverhalten zu nötigen und dazu zu
bringen sich Ratschläge anzuhören die
teilweise albern aber teilweise auch
nicht albern sind eine wichtige Sache
wurde da vergessen wenn sie keinen Strom
haben können Sie auch wieder Toilette
nicht benutzen und das ist
wahrscheinlich der größerer Gau und es
wird wahrscheinlich ein Stromausfall
geben dass die Gasspeicher gefüllt sind
das sagt gar nichts das können die
Leitungen unterbrochen werden und wenn
es keinen Strom gibt können Sie kein
Wasser in den dritten Stock Pumpen und
Sie können auch nicht tanken an der
Tankstelle also die Wahrscheinlichkeit
im Blackout den ich mir nicht wünsche
ist sehr groß andererseits sehe ich
schon ein gewisses abenteuerbedürfnis
darin nicht das ist es gab mal so ein
berühmten Schnee Winter wo Leute bei
Kiel im Zug eingeschneit worden die
haben davon noch 10 Jahre geschwärmt
nicht man kann sich näher man kommt der
kuscheln und dann hat man eine
Katastrophe überlebt es gibt ein großes
Bedürfnis in Deutschland nach
Katastrophen und nach überleben ich
glaube wir sind jetzt da wo 45 aufgehört
hat Herr Stahl merken Sie das auch wenn
Bürgern ihnen schreiben haben die so
richtig Bock auf Katastrophe und
Überlebensdrang wie er Bruder ist
genannt hat ich spüre das nicht so rosig
wie Herr Broder das sagt sondern ich
spüre das schon knallhart denn viele
Menschen da draußen sehen mich als
jemand der für sie die Stimme erhebt und
ich höre jeden Tag und lese jeden Tag
die Angst der Menschen wie verzweifelt
sie sind dass sie nicht wissen wie sie
ihre Energiekosten bezahlen kann dass
sie Angst davor haben ein
Blackout könnte eintreten was dann alle
damit folgt ich komme aus Berlin Neuköln
ich bin auf der Straße groß geworden ich
kann mich mit Gewalt aus ich weiß wie
schnell sie entsteht wenn Plünderung
entstehen oder Gewalt entstehen oder
dann noch andere schlimme Dinge also ich
sehe das nicht so rosig ja wie
vielleicht jetzt Sie vielleicht das
jetzt gerade erklären ich finde es auch
schön gemäß ich weiß ich persönlich höre
diese Angst und dieser Verzweiflung und
dann sehe ich eine Politik die ein
Haufen Scheiße erzählt die Almosen
verteilt wir brauchen einen gasdeckel
der für alle wirklich wird und wenn
diese Politik weiterhin
machen Sie sie feiern sich im
Oktoberfest keine Masken offensichtlich
das ist eine mit 13 Euro kriegen feiern
sie sich das ist der Platz selbst gegen
die maskenpflicht eigentlich müssten sie
doch die Politiker gut finden die jetzt
auch mal sagen es reicht nach
zweieinhalb Jahren oder also
grundsätzlich bin ich gegen die
Maßnahmen weil ich einfach die Meinung
bin wir haben jetzt genug wir müssen
damit leben und das sagte Herr Buschmann
aber wir haben ein paar Fanatiker haben
besessen Leute erlauterbach ist der
größte davon werden schon wundert jetzt
hat er vier Tage nicht getötet
wahrscheinlich nichts daran dass er mit
seinem Spruch mit wir sind im Krieg mit
Putin wahrscheinlich einfach etwas
losgelöst hat dass die Leute jetzt
wirklich sagen mehr scheiße geht nicht
und dann andere denken aber es ist ja
eine Geschichte wenn man etwas fordert
und die sagen wir sollen was nun an
manchen besonders unsere Kinder sollen
jetzt bald wieder Masken kann dann
müssen sie das auch vormachen wenn sie
nicht vormachen finde ich sehr
eigentlich gut weil dann sollen sie
endlich wieder scheiße aus wie findest
Heuchelei es ist eine verlogene
doppelmoralische und noch mal wenn
wieder wenn die so ein Maß haben weil 13
€ der eine Kuh kostet riesen
Fleischplatte vor sich 13 80 mit
Trinkgeld 15
€, aber wir haben daraus Menschen die
nicht wissen wie sie ihre Rechnung
bezahlen sollen die die Inflationsrate
sehen die nicht mehr haltbar ist dann
findet er den hohen auf die Verarmung
kommen wir auch später heute in der
Sendung zurück Herr Straßburger wie
empfinden Sie es denn die aktuelle ich
ich empfinde schon als Blackout Panik
muss ich sagen ich denke mir schon die
Politik kann man ganz runter fahren ja
also mich erinnern das tatsächlich aus
der Kontext ist schon gefallen hier mit
äh corvit also ich sehe da auch eine
gewisse Kontinuität in der Bevormundung
des Bürgers also das praktisch die
Politik kommt und sagt ja wie sollen wir
uns verhalten wie sollen wir Hände
waschen wir sollen wir zu Hause heizen
wie lange sollen wir duschen und so
weiter und das ist für mich ein bisschen
befremdlich also ich muss sagen ich
komme ja auch ursprünglich aus Warschau
ich habe ja auch schon ein noch ein paar
Jahre praktisch der das damaligen
Systems in der Volksrepublik wollen
empfunden erlebt und ein paar
Erinnerungen kommen dabei hoch eben eine
eine Politik die meint Bildung betreiben
zu müssen in einem sehr plakative Art
und Weise und
es ist nicht an nicht die Frage warum
die Politik das macht dann müsste man
vielleicht die Politik fragen warum sie
das eigentlich machen
aber ich fühle ein Unbehagen ich glaube
ich bin verantwortlich genug meine
Eltern haben mich erzogen und paar
andere Leute um mich herum und jetzt bin
ich auch erwachsen genug um zu sagen
okay das und das kann ich in meinem
Leben machen heute noch eine Wohnung in
Warschau wenn ich das hier erwähnen darf
das heißt sie haben eigentlich zwei aber
ja aber das heißt wenn sie jetzt
wirklich in der Not würden sie dann in
Berlin oder Warschau wo haben sie mehr
vertrauen
oh das ist die Zeit noch hin und her zu
schwere Frage es wäre Frage
[Musik]
ob das
zusammenhängt praktisch mit der mit der
Klima also mit mit der mit den
Heizkosten oder damit mit der Situation
der Wohnsituation da bin ich mir
unsicher insofern als Kate Polen hat
jetzt ein bisschen auch eine andere
Politik die es im Hinblick auf die
Ressourcen für dass es gibt hier diese
Ball bleiben zwischen Norwegen und Polen
das wissen sie alle hier und das ist
noch mal ein Versuch das ein bisschen
anders abzusichern ich bin kein Fachmann
um das hier zu vergleichen und zu sagen
wo bin ich dann tatsächlich sicherer
emotionale Frage
also ich empfinde keine Panik weil ich
mich bislang irgendwie nicht in Panik
versetzen lasse aber ich habe das
durchgemacht am Anfang des kurvits also
da hatte ich tatsächlich irgendwie ich
habe es nicht verstanden was los ist ich
habe mich gefragt ja wie kann das jetzt
auf einmal sein in dem vereinten Europa
ich kann mein Vater der in Warschau
wohnt und mein er wohnt in der Wohnung
auf einmal vielleicht gar nicht besuchen
weil mir eine bundesreg Anfang gesagt ja
ich darf jetzt nicht die Grenze
überfahren oder die polnische Regierung
will mir sagen da darf nicht ich hier
bleiben ich habe zwei
Staatsangehörigkeiten und wie mein Vater
da und ich hier und wie soll das
funktionieren
vereinigte Europa
lässt mich nicht in eine Nachbarstadt
fahren weil was ich meine wird da
schlimmer sein mit als hier oder das
habe ich nicht verstanden und das die
Zeiten nie wieder erleben Herr Freund
die Frage hier an Sie wenn Sie jetzt auf
die würden sie es auch als Bevormundung
beschreiben wie ich es ja getan habe
also diese Stimmung Licht aus weniger
heizen ist es ja auch ein paar schöne
Beispiele gebracht hier innenpolitisch
mit dem Bier gibt ein paar andere Sachen
wir machen jetzt eine Fußball-WM mit
gekühlten Stadien im Winter in Katar die
tollsten Sachen in der frage ich mich so
ein bisschen das kann man es leisten wir
zu Hause sollen dann wir haben euch
immer sagt dann den Gürtel enger
schnallen und sollen dann kalt duschen
das kannst ja nicht gewesen sein die
Politik nein also die Politik muss dafür
sorgen dass auch breite BEV Schichten
und nicht nur einige Ebenen Genuss
kommen das ist eben abgefedert wird und
wir haben eben zur Zeit in Europa Krieg
und wir müssen eben mit den Konsequenzen
leben und schon sehen die Politik kann
dafür nicht sorgen das ist schon wenn
sie von falschen Prämissen ausgehen
kommen Sie automatisch zu falschen
Ergebnisse ja die Politiker ist als
machtlos und willenlos erwiesen und nein
es war vieles absehbar es war eine
Politik des Durchhaltens des
durchwurststands wir hatten 16 Jahre
Stillstand und es ist auch unfair Frau
Merkel dafür verantwortlich zu machen
hier gilt wieder das Führerprinzip
wissen sie Merkel ist an allem schuld
oder man Merkel ist nur gewusst hätte
nein das ganze Land war eine Art
Tiefkühlung vollkommen Recht nur jetzt
zur Zeit damit gerechnet das jetzt
passiert und die Aufgabe der Politik
wäre ein bisschen vorauszusehen warum
sagen Sie das die Politik nicht dafür
Verantwortung tragen kann dass wir jetzt
eine Krise haben ich meine wenn wenn die
bundesrepubliker davon Europa Eintritt
in einem Krieg also wir befinden uns
jetzt nicht direkt in einem Krieg aber
wir haben uns Verbündete eine
Kriegspartei aber wir sollten verbündet
mit einer Kriegspartei und ich meine
wenn man eine solche Entscheidung trifft
und dann sozusagen in Anführungsstrichen
unter dieser Voraussetzung man sieht in
den Krieg mit einem Gegner sonst 40%
unseres Gas liefert dann gibt's doch
irgendwie auch eine Entscheidungsfindung
die uns sagt wie soll ich denn Krieg
machen gegenüber einen von denen ich
völlig ener gut man kann natürlich auch
vorsorglich kapitulieren weil man von
jemand abhängig ist das machen zum
Beispiel geschlagene Ehefrauen die sich
in ihr Schicksal fügen aber das meinte
ich gar nicht ihr meinte nur dass die
Situation der Energieknappheit Watt
voraussehbar und die Leute diese
Situation übersehen oder sogar
herbeigeführt haben mit ihren Fantasien
von Elektroautos und von flottierenden
elektrospeichern die sind für die
Situation verantwortlich wälzen das aber
danach uns ab ich weigere mich kürzer
dadurch nicht weigere mich ein
Waschlappen zu benutzen ich habe wie sie
die ersten 11 Jahre meines Lebens in
Polen verbracht und ich habe eine
Waschlappen Allergie seitdem ja und
jetzt erzählen uns jetzt dass wir dafür
verantwortlich sind was die versaut
haben oder an der Stelle mache ich nicht